but first let's just show you some
pictures coming into Us from Southern
Ukraine and uh President Vladimir
zielinski has visited regions devastated
by the flooding after about a down
rather was blown up in
russian-controlled territory this is
near kerson which has been taken by the
Russians this is a video that was posted
from the telegram messaging app and you
can see President zielinski there
um talking to people troops on the
ground trying to organize rescues and he
said the immediate priority was rescuing
stranded people as well as getting food
and water to the region There's real
concern about disease with those Rising
flood waters there as well as access to
food as well of course agricultural land
also covered by the flood so real
concerns about the future as well as
well as the immediate impact on people
living in that area so you can see
President Vladimir zielinsky visiting
the regions affected this morning